In this optional section what I want to do
is revisit the concept of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors, in case you’ve forgotten what
they are. They are a concept that we’re
going to need in the next segment.
So let’s consider a simple linear algebra
case. We have a vector, v. It’s an Nx1 vector,
and we’re going to pre-multiply it by a
square matrix NxN, and the result will of
course be a vector, an Nx1 vector.
Now for every matrix ‘A’, there are N
vectors whose direction is unchanged by A.
That means the vector v and the vector v prime
will be parallel to each other. And these
vectors we refer to as eigenvectors.
Now, although the vector v and the vector
v prime will be parallel, they may not be
necessarily the same length. So the length
is scaled by the eigenvalue that corresponds
to the eigenvector.
So that’s a lot of words. Let’s look at
a graphical example of this in practice.
We’ve chosen a very simple A matrix; it’s
a 2 by 2 matrix, so there will be two eigenvectors
and eigenvalues. And you can see an eigenvalue
just about coming up … now. That’s the
case where the red vector, the input vector,
and the blue output vector are parallel to
one another. There’s another one … now.
Notice that they are parallel to each other
but they’re not the same length. So the
ratio of the length of the red vector to the
blue vector is the eigenvalue.
So the term eigenvector … it’s a German
word and it means ‘own vector’. It’s
a special vector that belongs to the matrix.
So there are a couple of equations that we
can write. First of all we can use the equation
that we had before: that v multiplied by the
matrix A gives us the output vector v prime.
And in the particular case when they’re
parallel then they are related by a scalar;
that the two vectors are parallel, only their
length is different. So we can represent that
by the scalar factor lambda, which is an eigenvalue.
So if these two equations are true we can
write this, and we’re following through
some maths. We’re not interested in the
case where v=0, we’re interested in the
case where the determinant of A minus lambda,
I, is equal to 0. So if we can write that
expression for any matrix, it’s easy for
a 2 by 2 case, more difficult for 3 by 3,
very, very difficult for bigger matrices,
and we can solve that for the values of the
eigenvalues; these lambda values.
Once we have values for lambda we can substitute
them into the equations above and then solve
for the eigenvector.
Now there are an infinite number of eigenvectors
corresponding to which eigenvalue, so typically
we choose eigenvectors that have got a unit
length. That’s an additional constraint
that helps us choose just a single eigenvector.
We’ll demonstrate this with a simple example:
with a 2 by 2 matrix.
The eigenvalues of this matrix are given simply
using the MATLAB built-in function eig. We
see the two eigenvalues are 1 and -2.
To find the eigenvectors is a little bit more
complex. We have to assign two output arguments
from the function eig, and the first output
argument which I’ve assigned to the matrix
x has got two columns. The first column is
the first eigenvector. The second column is
the second eigenvector. And the eigenvalues
now are arranged along the diagonal of the
output matrix e.
A fundamental property of the eigenvector
is that when it is transformed by the original
matrix, it is parallel to itself. Let’s
test that.
The original matrix A, and we multiply it
by the first eigenvector which is the first
column of the matrix x. We see that the resulting
vector is indeed parallel to the eigenvector,
and it has exactly the same magnitude. It’s
been scaled by 1, and that is the value of
the first eigenvalue. So the eigenvector multiplied
by the matrix A is a vector parallel to the
eigenvector with a scale factor of 1. So it
is, in fact, the original eigenvector.
Let’s try it with the other eigenvector,
which is the second column of the matrix x.
We see now that the result is indeed parallel
to the second eigenvector, but it’s been
scaled by -2, and -2 is the second eigenvalue
of the matrix A.